imagine for a moment that apart from the
sun there is not a single star in the
radius of a billion light years from our
earth
a dark starless sky and limitless empty
space
envelop our system looking through an
optical telescope is pointless
all we see is planets of the solar
system and nothing more
there is no polar star to guide us in
our search for the north
there is no serious or vega only the
solitary
moon roams the sky night in night out
indifferently glowing and beautifully
reflecting sunlight
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
just imagine what a stupendous portion
of our cultural heritage
would never have been around a great
number of myths and legends
have to do with the stars it goes
without saying that any
travels to other stellar systems would
be out of the question
even a few light years is an
overwhelming distance for man
even at this point of our scientific
progress as for covering several hundred
million
light years the mere thought is no more
than just a fanciful dream
it would take man inventing extremely
powerful and advanced telescopes to be
able to see that the sun was not the
only star in our universe
but would they ever be invented there is
no way of finding it out
especially if we take into account the
fact that it is stars themselves that
have always been a powerful stimulus for
man to try to get to the bottom of the
nature of the universe
chances are that a bleak dark sky would
never have fascinated people
and as a result no modern devices and
equipment for observing space
would ever have been developed in one of
our previous videos i've already told
you about gargantuar and cosmic voids
or else i take it you would have heard
about these
voids are large scale expanses of space
that are almost
or completely devoid of galaxies or
galaxy clusters
these enormous objects take up about
fifty percent of the observable universe
the average void measures approximately
forty mega per sec
or one hundred thirty million light
years however the diameter of champion
voids
may reach several hundred million or
even a billion light years
these extra large voids are rather
predictably referred to as supervoids
the density of matter in these regions
is much less than in other areas of the
universe and
accounts for less than 10 percent of the
average density in meta galaxy
voids are the largest formations among
the large-scale structures of the
universe
on a par with galactic filaments or
thread-like formations
cosmology today explains their existence
by diversity of matter when the universe
was formed
one of the largest voids ever discovered
is the canis veneticis supervoid
spotted in 1988 this supervoid
is the second largest void known to
science today
with a diameter measuring a staggering
300 to 400 megaparsec
or a billion light years the canis
veneticius supervoid is located
1.5 billion light years away from our
earth
interestingly just 17 galaxy clusters
are located in this area of
mind-boggling dimensions and this is
extremely little for such
an incredibly enormous expansive space
all the 17 clusters are gathered within
a comparatively small area by space
standards
namely within a measly 150 million light
years
if any gravitational interaction between
them does take place
more advanced technologies are called
for to detect it
the diameter of the canis venetici
supervoid
accounts for approximately one percent
of that of the observable universe it
could easily accommodate
10 000 galaxies identical to the milky
way in terms of dimensions
who knows perhaps there are life forms
on a planet hidden somewhere in these 17
clusters
however there is no way light from our
sun will ever reach those parts
and any interaction with potential
inhabitants of those parts of the
universe is effectively
out of the question now what is a
billion light years
the history of multicellular life forms
on our earth
starting from primitive cylinderate
animals counts just over 800 million
years
in other words life on our planets
evolved from colonies of protozoans to
humans
in the time a photon traveled from one
edge of the supervoid to the other
it takes some stars less time to
complete their entire life cycle
from getting born to going supernova or
finishing life in an alternative way
actually covering this distance in a
spaceship romantic as it is
sounds like a recklessly eccentric idea
in order to understand what space inside
a void is like
you have to think of a deep physical
vacuum it may contain
interstellar gas clouds independent star
clusters or even galaxies
but most of the supervoid contains
nothing the name
is self-explanatory of course space
expenses are for the most part vacuum
just to give you an idea about the
proportions there is a cubic centimeter
of dense stellar matter to thousands of
cubic kilometers of space
but even this space is not completely
empty
a mark of a hundred kilometers above
ground is the accepted limit of the
earth's atmosphere
at this height the atmospheric pressure
is so small that it becomes comparable
to that of solar wind
however there is no clearly defined
transition to space
and even several hundred kilometers
above the earth's surface
there can be found an extremely small
amount of gas molecules from our
atmosphere
seemingly negligible these molecules
still manage to slow down
artificial satellites orbiting our
planet
as a result many of them have to
regularly adjust to their
orbit in order not to lose their
momentum and not to have to get back to
earth prematurely
gas concentration is much lower the
further we are from a planet
but even beyond our solar system and
away from any star or planet
there will always be at least a few
molecules of hydrogen
in every cubic centimeter of space
in addition to that there will be solar
wind in space
a current of high energy subatomic
particles emitted by the sun
and of course other things have to be
reckoned with like radiation of distant
stars
relic radiation and neutrinos subatomic
particles particularly hard to detect
the vacuum inside the void is deep to
such a point that there is less than
half a molecule of matter for every
cubic centimeter of space
besides all sources of radiation are so
remote from it
that the density of their radiation is
quite negligible compared to relic
radiation
as a result all that remains is
undetectable neutrinos
and the cosmic microwave background
as i've mentioned before there is
something else to be found inside the
incredibly vast expanses of the void
apart from deep vacuum there are also
clouds of interstellar gas
the future nursery for stars and
galaxies
secondly dark matter is supposed to be
found inside
supervoids but today's methods of
detection are hardly adequate for
studying it
it should be noted that the overwhelming
majority of voids detected so far are
located hundreds of millions of light
years away from the solar system
in essence what we are observing now is
the distant past of these formations
only one void lies relatively close to
the local group of galaxies
among them the milky way and is referred
to as the local void
its diameter measures approximately 180
million light years
and the distance between the sun and the
void's center is about
90 million light years
the boutais void is another large
formation about 700 million light years
away from the sun
the diameter of this void measures
approximately 330 million light years
which is about 0.35 percent of the
diameter of the observable universe
the boaters void was discovered in 1981
by
a group of scientists headed by robert
kirschner with theoretical arguments in
favor of the existence of supervoids
having been formulated 20 years
previously
the supervoid is thought to have been
formed as a result of several smaller
voids blending together
just 60 galaxies have been pinpointed
inside the boaters void by now
although such staggering expanses could
easily have accommodated about two
thousand
speaking about the most mysterious void
in the universe
it lies three billion light years away
from the sun
it is known as the cmb cold spot or the
eridanus supervoid
this supervoid is a champion even by
supervoid standards
with a diameter measuring 1.8 billion
light years
it may easily have accommodated 18 000
galaxies
similar to the milky way
the iridonous supervoids temperature is
from 70 to 150 degrees micro kelvin
colder than the average
cmb temperature of the universe
today's theory of the universe's origin
cannot give a definite explanation to
this fact
this so did not fit into the accepted
theory in cosmology
that at first the measurements were
dismissed as faulty and the equipment
was blamed
only after several years of scrupulous
measurement where the reading is finally
accepted
a great number of explanations including
rather extravagant ones were offered
concerning the strange temperature
properties
one hypothesis has it that the
anomalously low cosmic microwave
background in the iridonous supervoid
is a result of the influence of
supermassive chunks of dark energy
according to another hypothesis this
area is what is left of another universe
that had existed before hours
be it as it may there is disappointingly
no definite answer yet
feel free to express your opinion about
all this hit the like button or leave a
comment
if you are new on our channel you are
welcome to subscribe
your support means a lot to us and
motivates us to improve further and
treat you to new videos
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you